Traduttore: Peggy-Anne Berthier
Revisore: Sofia Ramundo
Salve a tutti.
Attraverso i confini…
Dunque, la prima cosa che ho pensato
quando ho visto il tema della giornata
è stata la parola "idee".
In fondo, conoscete qualcosa
di più straordinario e potente
delle idee nel superare i confini?
Confini geografici, confini del tempo,
passando di generazione in generazione.
Confini del pregiudizio.
Le idee hanno una straordinaria
forza propulsiva
e sembra che sia quasi impossibile
alzare delle barriere o dei muri
per impedire loro di muoversi.
E le idee, come diceva Giovanni Falcone,
che mi piace particolarmente ricordare
in questa giornata, viaggiano e camminano
sulle gambe degli uomini.
Ecco, in questo viaggio breve
vorrei concentrarmi con voi
su un particolare tipo di idee,
ossia la conoscenza scientifica,
la conoscenza tecnica,
la conoscenza specialistica.
E su quegli uomini che sono,
sulle loro gambe,
portatori di questo tipo di conoscenza.
Quelli che nel dibattito chiamiamo
i "cervelli", o se preferite i "talenti",
o ancora con un'espressione molto usata
(che però a me non piace tantissimo...)
il "capitale umano".
Non è un gran periodo per parlare
di capitale umano e di cervelli,
perché, diciamo,
siamo circondati da studi che ci dicono
che l'analfabetismo funzionale dilaga.
Che non riusciamo a leggere
testi più lunghi di tre righe,
che il nostro schema di apprendimento
è sempre più visivo e fotografico
e sempre meno analitico.
E quindi, diciamo, non andiamo molto
di moda in questi quindici minuti…
Eppure quello della conoscenza è un asset
fondamentale e vi do un primo elemento.
La conoscenza produce ricchezza.
Se prendiamo i Paesi europei e misuriamo,
da un lato, la crescita del loro
benessere economico, usiamo il PIL e,
dall'altro, la percentuale
di laureati che è, diciamo,
sul totale della popolazione giovane,
"giovane" vuol dire fra i 25 e i 34 anni,
ci accorgiamo che le due cose, conoscenza
e crescita del benessere economico,
viaggiano in simbiosi,
viaggiano a braccetto.
Se c'è l’una cresce l'altra.
E la traiettoria evolutiva congiunta,
la vedete evidenziata da quella retta
scura che visualizzate alle mie spalle.
Non c'è nessun trucco, eh! Nessuna magia:
la parola chiave è produttività.
Se io ho più conoscenze il mio lavoro
diventa più efficiente,
più efficace, più produttivo,
genera di più con un minore sforzo.
E chiaramente questo è un requisito
indispensabile per lo sviluppo economico.
Pensate che in Germania
i lavoratori lavorano in media
tra le 30 e le 36 ore settimanali.
Noi in Italia siamo a 42.
Beh, diciamo così, il nostro PIL cresce
un po' meno del loro, capite?
Mi verrebbe da dire,
quanto lavoro per niente…
Quanto sforzo per niente!
E la risposta sta lì. Più competenze,
più conoscenze, più produttività.
E questa è la differenza
fra la Germania e noi.
Vi do un modo diverso di vedere la cosa.
Un po' più micro-geograficamente,
alle mie spalle vedete
il risultato di uno studio che,
col mio team all'Università Cattaneo-LIUC,
abbiamo chiuso circa un anno fa.
Ci siamo inventati un indicatore
che misura quanto i territori lombardi
sono attrattivi verso le imprese
(è la mappa a sinistra),
e l'abbiamo messo a confronto
con la distribuzione della conoscenza
e dei cervelli sul territorio.
Colori scuri, azzurri e blu:
fenomeno sgonfio.
Mentre, dove vedete i gialli e i rossi,
quei territori sono carichi.
Ora, è ovvio che le due mappe
non si sovrappongano del tutto,
ma guardate quante analogie!
Il messaggio che ne esce
è che la distribuzione e la presenza
di cervellie e di capitale umano
sul territorio attrae le imprese.
Il che è un altro elemento forte a favore
della rilevanza strategica
della conoscenza.
Giusto per essere sicuri
di non sbagliarci,
abbiamo poi intervistato un bel numero
di imprese del territorio lombardo
e loro ci hanno detto
che le scelte localizzative,
cioè decidere dove insediarsi,
dipendono per quasi il 40%
dalla disponibilità
di capitale umano sul territorio.
Direi che è una cosa straordinaria!
Volete sapere come siamo messi a Varese?
L’istogramma ve lo dice:
siamo la seconda provincia lombarda
dopo la città metropolitana,
quindi l’enclave Milano-Monza-Brianza.
Il che ci pone anche
ai primissimi posti in Europa.
La distribuzione sul territorio
è quella che vedete nelle mappe.
Quella strana cosa a forma di barbapapà
è la provincia di Varese.
Io dico sempre barbapapà ai miei studenti.
Poi sgranano gli occhi e capisco
che la mia datazione al carbonio
non si sovrappone con la loro,
quindi vabbè è un barbapapà, insomma.
Allora, il fenomeno sta… (APPLAUSI)
Il fenomeno si concentra
nel cuore (capoluogo) e nella pancia,
ma quello che più mi interessa
è quell’asse che vedete
dal capoluogo verso il Lago Maggiore
perché quello è un asse
che non è ricchissimo di imprese,
però ha le imprese giuste.
Ha le imprese che abbiamo
visualizzato sulla destra,
quelle imprese che innovano molto
e che sono le protagoniste nell'utilizzo
proprio dei cervelli e della conoscenza.
Allora, facciamo il punto.
Conoscenza vuol dire ricchezza,
vuol dire (in questo caso)
attrazione di imprese,
vuol dire imprese innovative.
Ci sarebbero gli ingredienti per dire:
investiamo a testa bassa!
Eppure abbiamo dei problemi.
Il primo problema sono i luoghi comuni.
Quante volte avete sentito dire:
ma serve ancora studiare?
Serve ancora avere un titolo di studio?
La risposta è qua:
l'occupazione giovanile in Italia
è al di sotto del 40%.
Per chi è portatore di un titolo di
scuola superiore sale a quasi il 50%.
E per chi ha una laurea
sale a quasi il 65%.
Gli stessi numeri valgono per tutta
l'Europa e per tutti i Paesi europei.
L’importante, però,
è che la conoscenza sia quella giusta,
quella che le imprese cercano.
E anche qui abbiamo un problema.
Perché da un’indagine OCSE scopriamo
che il 60% dei lavoratori italiani
ha un livello di qualifica e di competenze
che non è adeguato al tipo di mansioni
che svolge: o è troppo elevato,
o è troppo scarso,
o è semplicemente diverso.
Quindi, il lavoro e lo studio a volte,
anzi, spesso, si incontrano poco.
Poi, abbiamo un terzo problema.
Questo forse è il più grave di tutti:
che, alla fine, di laureati
ne produciamo troppo pochi
e siamo sistematicamente in coda a tutte
le graduatorie dei Paesi industrializzati,
sia in totale, sia se ci limitiamo
a guardare le generazioni più giovani,
cioè quelle che hanno tra 25 e 34 anni.
Infine, l'ultimo problema.
Che è questo: anche quando i laureati
e i cervelli li produciamo,
ce li facciamo scappare.
Questa mappa dell'Europa vi racconta
quali sono i flussi di cervelli
nel territorio europeo.
I Paesi scuri sono quelli che attraggono.
Il pallore dell'Italia è sconcertante.
E in Italia, anche la Lombardia,
purtroppo, in questo caso,
ha un colorino proprio pallido pallido,
che fa un po' venire i brividi.
Il problema c'è.
Il problema è il gap tra la rilevanza
strategica dell'asset "conoscenza",
dell’asset "cervelli" e, dall'altra parte,
queste difficoltà che abbiamo nel vincere
la scommessa della conoscenza.
Ora, mi viene da fare una proposta,
naturalmente retorica, detta qui,
ma molto concreta non appena
avremo finito questa chiacchierata.
Ed è quella di un patto territoriale
per la conoscenza in cui
tutti facciano la loro parte.
La dovrebbero fare le imprese
che dovrebbero, come dire,
aprire di più le porte a certe figure
professionali e soprattutto guardare
a quel tipo di produzioni,
altamente innovative,
che così tanto intensivamente
usano la conoscenza.
La dovrebbe fare il sistema
pubblico-privato, mettendo magari
qualche risorsa in più non solo
per la ricerca in sé,
ma per le borse di studio per favorire
i giovani che hanno voglia di studiare
e i laureati che hanno voglia
di continuare a fare un'attività
di questo tipo.
E dovrebbero farla le università. Tutte.
Qui ci sono solo alcuni punti che ci
interesserebbe far crescere e sviluppare.
Coinvolgere di più i giovani
nella costruzione dei progetti formativi.
Arricchire la nostra attività didattica
di esperienze concrete più di quanto già,
per esempio noi, nel nostro piccolo,
cerchiamo di fare.
Lavorare più a stretto contatto con le
imprese, soprattutto quelle medio-piccole.
E poi la formazione permanente,
cioè guardare anche a quei signori
che il titolo di studio l’hanno portato
a casa magari qualche annetto fa,
ma hanno voglia di aggiornarsi,
di crescere,
di maturare nuove consapevolezze,
anche a livello professionale.
Ora, ripeto, la proposta può sembrare
un pochettino retorica.
E qualcuno starà pensando: ma davvero
serve a qualcosa questa cosa qua?
Vi do l'ultimo blocco di numeri.
Esiste, ed è stata pubblicata di recente
una ricerca europea che ci dice
che l'insieme di tutte
le università europee ha generato nel 2017
(sono gli ultimi dati disponibili) circa
400 miliardi di euro di valore aggiunto.
È un concetto e anche
un ordine di grandezza che,
forse, per noi
è un po' difficile calare a terra.
E allora che cosa abbiamo provato a fare
noi, in LIUC, nel nostro piccolo?
Clonare quell'algoritmo e provare
a ragionare su di noi.
E quello che abbiamo tirato fuori
lo vedete alle mie spalle.
Ogni 100 laureati che escono dalle nostre
aule noi riusciamo ad attivare,
più che noi, loro, una serie di circuiti
economici virtuosi che tradotti in termini
diciamo, finanziario-monetari equivalgono
a 100, quasi 100 milioni di euro di PIL.
Questo dato vi risulta ancora poco facile
da fare atterrare sul pianeta?
Allora vi do l'ultimo che credo,
diciamo così, sia la vera chiave di volta.
Questa roba ha un'implicazione
a livello occupazionale.
PIL vuol dire posti di lavoro
e allora ci siamo inventati
il "moltiplicatore dei cervelli".
Cioè, ci siamo chiesti:
ma per ogni laureato che produciamo,
i circuiti economici che questo fanciullo
o questa fanciulla attiva, sviluppa,
sostiene, nutre, generano posti di lavoro?
Certo che sì! L’economia che questi
circuiti attivano genera posti di lavoro.
E il numero è questo:
ogni laureato, 250 posti di lavoro.
La parola moltiplicatore mi sembra
funzioni bene: 1 a 250.
Ed è perfetta: quando si parla di idee,
di conoscenza, di cervelli,
la parola moltiplicazione è perfetta.
Ricordate George Bernard Shaw:
se due uomini che hanno una mela
si incontrano e si scambiano la mela
ognuno va a casa con due mele.
Ma se si scambiano… Con una mela,
scusate… se si scambiano un'idea
vanno entrambi a casa con due idee.
Grazie.
(Applausi)